thanks very much for joining us at mr.
Johnson is it no time for this alternate
tournament at Boris island well yeah I
think we will ultimately get back to
that solution or one like it yes I think
that's it that's inevitably going to
come back on the table I think what
people will say tonight is that the
government's indecision as it were is
all part of a kind of fudge to get
beyond the mayor or elections next year
and and then to have another go I have
to tell you I think it's much more
important much more significant than
that I think the difficulties of
building a third runway at Heathrow
Airport are really becoming very very
obvious to everybody it's not just the
air pollution it's not just the noise
pollution catastrophic though that would
be the real problem is it's so short
term it's so pathetically unambitious
for a country like Britain that actually
needs a full runway five runway hard
airport if we're going to compete in the
long term and and that's why I think
your initial question was was well posed
at mr. Johnson I mean what then was the
point of the Davis Commissioner man
David Cameron said back in 2009 no third
runway at heathrow you know politics
sometimes changes a man let's say that
he was in government for a while
launched this commission it published
its recommendations why have they not
been acted upon well I think the point
of the Davis Commission and you asked a
very good question was was really to
satisfy the the Treasury and debarment
rattled the great mass of British civil
servant who for a long time and and the
CBI and others who for a long time had
been campaigning to revive the old idea
of a third runway at heathrow and to
give the government the excuse to go
ahead and for the prime minister to to
break his promise and that was the
objective to get a pretext for a u-turn
to get camouflage for a political u-turn
I think what's happened in the last few
weeks and months is it really has become
obvious to everybody involved with the
issue that it is really much more
complicated than the Howard Davis report
made clear the air quality pollution
issues are the air pollution issues are
very very serious indeed the noise
pollution issues are basically in
soluble if you're going to have planes
flying over the whole of London to get
to the to the airport and then as I say
there's this basic knockout problem but
because of the constraints of the site
you can't deliver the long-term capacity
that London and this country needs I
think one of the most tragic things is
the confusion of people in cities around
the UK who are waking up to the
realization that they will not actually
get those extra communications into
Heathrow those extra slots that they
thought they would as a result of
getting a third runway and indeed a
third runway does not even give you that
a huge number of extra slots extra
destinations around the world doesn't
drink so that's a good 10 tonight she
here I'm gonna enter key and ask how
much of this it is about pure politics
about the man who may well succeed you
at City Hall Zac Goldsmith in a few days
ago he said if there was a legitimate
reason put forward to put a pause on
this decision I would not have to resign
from my position it does look as if
behind the scenes there has been some
pressure exactly perhaps by individuals
including yourself look I mean of course
people as I said right at the beginning
I think people are going to say this is
all a great sort of government fire
armor and its annotate along grassing
maneuver and all that sort of thing of
course they're going to say that and I i
perfectly understand that i happen to
think that it's becoming clear to a lot
of people that there's a reason why in
the last 40 50 years this country has
not built an extra runway at London
Heathrow and it has not gone the way of
many other European capitals and indeed
our competitor cabals in Asia and
elsewhere just because that is the wrong
place to build another runway yes we
need is another demonstration we need a
full runway airport but it's not the
right place isn't that just a
demonstration of the inertia that exists
within our political system the United
Kingdom when you have to you know really
fun heavily funded at blocks arguing
with government this has been going on
for decades I know and my that's why if
I may say so I think you were right when
you
your first question I think we need to
get back to the long-term solutions and
there are good long-term solutions
Transport for London did a lot of
modeling a lot of research on the
engineering they looked at all the
transport benefits all the economic
benefits I think about 964 billion
pounds worth of growth would result from
having a full runway 24 hour estuary
airport with virtually no noise dis
benefits for people living in the area
massive jobs growth a massive boost for
the UK economy and inner show the words
that you just used for me totally sums
up this debate even the Heathrow option
is itself in a way the do-nothing option
because you're just concentrating you're
just going on with the same old solution
in a place that doesn't really offer
long-term prospects for growth and even
if we were to build it and I don't think
we will in 10-15 pretty years time
believe me we'd be having exactly the
same agonizing conversation you've
mentioned a few times concerns around
air pollution wow that third runway to
be placed Heathrow may the Davis
Commission itself left the door open to
an all of this by saying look we prefer
Heathrow but we still have some concerns
what's your understanding of the rule
that the Volkswagen emissions scandal
might well have played in all of this I
think it certainly had a political
impact in the sense that it greatly
escalated people's consciousness of the
fal ability of air quality tests and
there's a great deal of alarm that we
may have been getting some false
readings from some of our some of our
site sits on actually that's not true we
have a pretty clear understanding of
where we are there's no question that if
you increase aviation capacity at
Heathrow you massively increase
vehicular pollution it's not the
kerosene being burnt by the planes as
they come on come down and take off it's
the vehicles around
that caused the tremendous build up of
fumes now that is very very difficult to
solve there is also i'm afraid the issue
of noise pollution government stated
policy is that you should not have an
increase in aviation capacity in a new
runway anywhere where new families new
homes can be brought into the noise
footprint a third runway at heathrow
would bring another 300,000 people into
that noise that noise footprint that
noise envelope that's completely
unacceptable there's no mayor in the
world there's no democracy in the world
that would allow that to happen there's
no other city that's contemplating
something of that kind and there's a
good reason for that hey mr. Johnson in
terms of where we go next from all of
this I'm a different well first of all
were you in any way knocked that you
weren't invited into number 10 for that
at that meeting with the Prime Minister
and cabinet colleagues I mean second do
you think there should be a vote in the
house well I mean on the first point I
would just remind you that I along with
I think virtually every other affected
member of the government actually
remember the government I think you know
Philip Hammond and Theresa May and
everybody else who's got a constituency
who was affected by the decision was it
specifically excluded from those meeting
says no problem then this cannot manage
that but should there be a vote in the
house I think you we need to get on and
and take a decision as fast as as
possible I think that it's time to
jettison the third runway chuck it
overboard it's been going on for too
long now forty years as a good reason
why it hasn't happened it ain't gonna
happen mr. Johnson I wonder if you just
hold there for just one second we just
want to play a little clip that we've
had one fact no we haven't quite got it
yet so I'm just asking what we'll do we
need to do all that again no no no no
this is live mr. Johnson just to make
absolute its life that's all right
that's collateral relief I don't know
the one that the one name that you
haven't really mentioned that often
during our discussion this evening as
that of the Prime Minister as that of
David Cameron because to an extent is
you mentioned us it does reflect upon
his leadership of the party it does
reflect upon at the leadership of the
country
you can't of course extricate yourself
from your role is made of London but it
is no the time for the Prime Minister to
not be a bit more prime ministerial well
I think the Prime Minister's view is
very clear and it's one that he
enunciated in 2009 and in the campaign
in 2010 as a everybody remembers it he
said no ifs no buts no third runway and
I think that was the right policy for
Dave then and it remains the right
policy today we were elected on it
together I think that it was it
reflected them very very serious
environmental obstacles in the way of
building a colossal new runway in the
middle of West London massively
disrupting the area building over the
m25 at a cost of about 15 billion pounds
which nobody by the way is stepping
forward to pay for it was the right
policy what we need is to think bigger
we should be more ambitious as a country
and I know that the Prime Minister and
the charts are very ambitious for this
country in their right to be so mr.
Johnson to stay with us were just a
moment we just want to we just heard
from the man who may well succeed Boris
Johnson at City Hall Zac Goldsmith
another opponent of the third runway I
think the government's made exactly the
right decision it is recognized finally
that the environmental case the
environmental questions are paramount as
I and campaigners and colleagues in
parliament have always said the
environmental obstacles at heathrow are
insurmountable so as far as I'm
concerned this decision effectively
moves he throw off the agenda and it
allows us now to focus on the real
alternatives mr. Johnson does that
decision from number 10 move he throw
off the agenda now I think zach is
completely right and as you can imagine
here I work very closely on this and we
share the same analysis and that is that
it's basically an environmental disaster
and bath
undeliverable and it's undeliverable in
a modern democracy we will go on now
circling over the over the run runway so
to speak in a appropriate metaphor but
in the end I'm afraid we'll have to go
off and find an alternative place to
land mr. Johnson quick prediction when
do you think work will start on a new
run week whatever that might be well you
know that as soon as we can get a
decision for expansion that is not at
heathrow not in the West London suburbs
but for the faster we can get clarity on
that the quicker the route to salvation
within this Parliament I sighs sincerely
hope mr. Johnson thanks very much for
your time this evening thank you so much
thank you thank you